[Music]
here we Kevin Frazier on the red carpet
of the purple carpet really at the
infinity war premiere how does the first
thing you guys have done a red carpet
together isn't weird unveiling that wall
right it's some laughing and joy I'm
just excited to share this experience
with him because I'm so excited to see
the film I haven't seen it before
[Music]
scarlet just made her 11 month
relationship with SNL's colin jost a red
carpet official but that's just one of
our favorite moments from the infinity
war premiere there was Gwyneth and those
legs she also flashed her a giant
sapphire engagement ring hi dad Bradley
Cooper just duh well begin hi and Chris
Hemsworth with his bro Luke
looking good after the recent accident
he had while vacationing with new BFF
Matt Damon how are you are you okay what
was the deal with the surfing act no
yeah it wasn't as bad as this and I was
kind of playing it up a bit
just started disagree with much left
more than a rock no sir if as if it's
fine though until last night I've
finished two hour and 40 minute film has
been a big secret even for the stars
nobody's seen the film literally nobody
I even thought Downey had seen the film
now he has nobody's seen it
usually what happens is that they roll
and then all of the actors run off and
have dinner somewhere but none of us
have seen it so everybody's staying I'm
excited I'm excited like a fan this time
how long till you let your son see this
movie oh I think we'll probably go next
weekend and he understands that he's I'm
an actor and we're all actors but he
gets just like me gets lost in the story
you play a character like Groot so that
you can share with your kids when the
boys see you and your daughter up there
I like they're very much like oh mama
you look pretty like a princess from Zoe
Saldana to Elizabeth Olsen the ladies
brought the fashion but for spider-man
Tom Holland it was all about family
what's it like having a superhero son
he's a superhero in real life really
[Music]
[Applause]